now that you're out you can be in love
with whoever you want you can go to
dinner with whoever you want you can
date whoever you want yeah have you
found love no not not yet not yet i i um
i think i'm finally at a place where i
can
receive it i'm tempted to set you up i
might have to i have some people in mind
that i think you would be good with it
you know i'm at least willing to go on
the uh howard stern blind date yeah
absolutely not not blind because the
gays care about aesthetic but right you
know
you said in an interview somewhere that
you um were at a party once and um you
got taylor swift's phone number it was
she was just being nice at a party like
i met her a couple times she's very very
sweet
um and uh
you know recently i i was at lena
dunham's wedding
and it's a picture of me and taylor that
i use on my grinder profile now like
i'll send it to guys you really want to
excite the gays in new york city send a
picture you and taylor swift some guys
don't believe me but i'm like
i started using the good i'm like i got
these snl promo pics let me use it on
grinder bro
yeah resources you attracted to uh
timothy chalamet who isn't that's the
thing he knows that he's wearing a
[ __ ] harness everyone him and harry
styles are dangerous it's like okay like
what are you okay the [ __ ] gay
baiters i saw harry styles in a [ __ ]
swamp yesterday i'm like why is this hot
right i'm into it i don't like that i'm
into it but i'm into it